we talked a bit about end-to-end
encryption already and a lot of the
assumption is that we have some kind of
symmetric key that we can use to talk
privately so you and me have some kind
of secret key and we use that to talk
securely diffie-hellman is how we get
that secret key diffie-hellman was first
published in 1976 and has become pretty
much a staple for any kind of
cryptography at all right whenever we
use cryptography we usually need to have
a symmetric key and to get that we often
have to perform some kind of difficult
it's so prevalent that your phone is
probably doing it right now right you're
you when you logged on to the browser to
watch this video you performed a
diffie-hellman key exchange when you
open up your phone and it connects to
any server it'll almost certainly
perform a difficult and key exchange if
not now then in the next few minutes
right it's it's unbelievably important
and unbelievably common the problem with
difficult is it's quite mathematically
complex it depends on your level of
mathematics so what I thought we'd do is
I thought we'd cover the mathematics in
the next row bits and then we look at a
kind of worked example of what actually
happens as an overview for both people
who just not interested in the
mathematics because they don't need to
implement it and they don't really
really mind so we'll do both and that
way hopefully there's something for
everyone we shall see
so perhaps diffie-hellman key exchanges
it's slightly miss named in the sense
that what we don't actually do is
exchange a key because then it will be
out in the public and we'd see it what
we actually do is exchange some public
variables and we combine them with some
private variables we've kept hidden so
that we can both create the same key all
right so we're actually creating a key
together in some sense so as always
we'll go back to Alice and Bob for this
so this have Alice over here right and
Bob over here I'm gonna sort of spread
this out a bit because we're going to
bring these in I don't wanna run out of
space right so Alice and Bob are here
these are their own machines and this is
the kind of public area
so anything that Alice and Bob send to
each other or agree on in public is
going to be in this area so as an
attacker if we want to break this key
exchange if we want to find out what the
secret key is we have to use these
variables to do it right and that
hopefully will explain why that's
difficult to do okay so the
thing is right at the beginning of per
ticket Hellman key exchange Alice and
Bob have to agree some mathematical
parameters that they're going to use
this is a value G or a generator and a
big prime number in all right now
for this example I'm going to use color
mixing to try and explain this I'm going
to write the letters in as well n won't
have a color for the sake of this
analogy G does right so G is going to be
let's go with yellow right now I'm going
to sort of squirt this in and hope that
it doesn't go everywhere in fact we kind
of need two copies of G really so let's
just sort of fill it up here up to about
I'm gonna get them the same so far so
good
so far it's not all over my desk close
enough right well it's kind of yellowy
often they're shared at the very
beginning of the handshake sometimes
they're just embedded in a standard or
everyone always uses the same one it
depends on the on the on the situation
it can take a little time and extra
message to send these things across so
sometimes having them stashed ahead of
time is a good idea so we've got G right
this is this is G now Alice to begin
with needs to calculate a private key
right will private variable I'm gonna
choose red for Alice there we go
probably couldn't use more food coloring
it's kind of pale red is that red close
enough what do you think it's
rose-colored yeah Bob is going to do the
same thing he's gonna have a private
value which is going to be blue now I
haven't chosen very interesing colors
that's simply because there aren't that
many colors available in the shops for
food coloring and I didn't go to that
much effort here we go
blue now these two colors are in their
private area this is this is a and this
is B so I'm going to label these this is
little a this is little B now the
important thing is that these are never
shared with anyone Alice doesn't share
this with the public Alice doesn't share
this with Bob now the first thing that
happens is that we need to combine the
private key with the generator to before
to produce a public key right now the
point is that once we've combined them
we can't I'll mix it right that's why
people like to use this color analogy
once we pour two colors together it's
difficult to know what colors went in
right because yes okay so if I pour red
into yellow it maybe make orange but it
could be but it was a bit more yellow
and a bit less red or you know it's
difficult to know right so it's kind of
orange for Alice
and Bob's gonna take his blue I can't
need them to be the same level really
and it does kind of make green this is a
bit orange II let's not critique me too
much and so yeah they're very different
to the originals and the important thing
is that we don't know what went into
here right we know G but we don't know a
and we can't find out so this is
actually this here this public key here
is a G in some sense it's got an A in it
it's got a G in it right this one has
got a B in it and it's got a G in it and
we can't extract the A's we can't
reverse this process now they then are
going to exchange these two public
variables but keep the private ones back
so we're going to sort of draw an arrow
over here and an arrow over here and
they going to switch them like this all
right so they get sent out in clear text
these are now in the public area because
they've been sent in plain text everyone
seen them all right so now as an
attacker I know
BG or Bob's public the part of his key
AG Alice's public component and G and n
I don't know anything else I don't know
what a and B are now this is the final
part difficulty can do all this in three
messages alice is going to take the
public component that Bob sent her and
add her private key and Bob is going to
take Alice's public component and add
his private key so we're going to get in
essence a mixture of a and B Angie right
that's the idea so let's do that now so
is that in the private domain yes this
will be done privately because visa
never needs in there were no tents so
these go into the private domain now I
mean I could make a copy of them that's
not so as it gonna add her read in so
let's go let's just add some wedge up to
about there it doesn't really work
because the register key faint and then
Bob adds in his blue which is going to
be like that
and hopefully this is where it all
doesn't work or does work these two
values are kind of the same I mean
they're not they're pretty close that's
a little bit darker perhaps because the
blue is a bit stronger considering
you've done that without
measuring everything yeah I mean
obviously good you would do this
normally with mathematical mathematical
functions that are much more precise in
my random squirting of liquids now so
those two are now in in the private VZ
yeah this is PO so Alice has taken Bob's
BG and added her a so that gets a B G
and Bob takes Alice is a G and gets a
the G by putting his be in there all
right now the order doesn't matter
remember just like mixing colors the
mathematics is such that if we adding B
first to G and then we add an A it's the
same as adding an a first so these two
values are exactly the same if you
wanted to try and recreate this as an
attacker you can't do it because you
have a G and VG's and G and so you could
mix these two together and you would get
a B G G in some sense mathematically
this is a little bit tenuous but we'll
talk about that any extra bits the point
is nothing in this public area can be
combined in any way to get this value or
this value which are the same the only
way to do that is to find out what a and
B are and the only way to do that is to
split up one of these two public
components which is very very difficult
to do all right and that's what's so
cool about difficult man in a few
messages we've sent some public but some
public numbers around and we've used our
private numbers to get a shared secret
that no one else can know now you would
generally do this at the beginning of
every conversation and you would use
this number
combined with perhaps some session
variables something like this to derive
secret keys for use in things like AES I
said this is actually going to be a
number which would vent her hash to turn
into an AES key or something like that
now the mathematics behind
diffie-hellman is usually modular
arithmetic we call that we have our
public numbers G and M G is often very
small is usually a small prime number n
is often very big and needs to be big
for the security abyss to work and is
often 2,000 bits long or 4,000 bits is
more common now